now I'll run git log on my new
repository to see what commits it has I
get the error message fatal bad default
revision head now how does gets name for
the current commit so this error message
is letting me know that I can't view my
commit history because there aren't any
commits yet to see that this really is a
git repository
I can run git status status is a command
I like to run frequently because it
shows which files have changed since the
last commit right now I can see that I'm
on the master branch we'll discuss what
that means later this lesson now git
would ordinarily show the most recent
commit but since there isn't one it says
initial commit here and get says that my
three files are untracked because it's
not tracking the history of those files
yet now go ahead and follow the same
steps to create a repository for your
reflections run the commands get an it
and get status in the directory where
you've created your reflections when
you're finished paste the output of git
status into this box